[Music]
thank you
out of all shots in the new tears of the
Kingdom trailer this one right here has
garnered a lot of attention and
excitement from fans and theorists alike
and for good reason there are so many
little secrets and details tucked away
in this short little sequence and the
mystery about what this dark and Eerie
Place could be has only increased by the
minute after about a week of analysis in
scrutiny I think it's all but confirmed
that this place is located somewhere
under the surface for one the
stalactites hanging from the ceiling are
a clear giveaway and as many have
pointed out the way the sound effects
reverberate through the environment like
the groans of these monsters and the
sound of the stone Hammer hitting the
ore suggests a large hollow space like a
cave of course this on its own is not
all that exciting we've already seen a
fair share of underground settings all
across the board by now I mean the 2019
teaser takes place almost entirely
inside of a giant Cavern there's a shot
from the 2021 footage where link is
bringing the pain to this new worm-like
creature hanging from the ceiling and
while the 2022 footage didn't show any
distinct Underground on settings we did
at least spot a cave entrance which
wasn't there in this location in breath
of the wild finally the 2023 footage has
two additional sequences which also seem
to be taking place below the surface
somewhere however none of these
locations are quite like this one
there's an alien otherworldly vibe to it
characteristics that aren't found in the
others not even in the 2019 footage the
air looks hazy and thick with strange
ash-like particles creeping around it
the unique vegetation like giant fungi
and unusual trees and plants the ghostly
Flames dancing around on the right side
of the frame and the sickly looking
malice infested enemies which so far are
seen in this area alone and nowhere else
in the footage all this combined has led
many to speculate that this place may be
more than just a weird looking cave
below ground somewhere but something far
more Sinister which if true could have
massive implications for not just the
lore of the series but also the way
tears of the Kingdom might be played but
before we get into the clues and details
about this place let's first establish
why the underground and its many layers
are not only significant but how it ties
into the greater conflict that has been
plaguing Hyrule since time immemorial
foreign
manual for the original Legend of Zelda
on the NES players were informed about
what it calls the underworld treacherous
labyrinths located beneath the Earth
filled to the brim with demonic entities
monsters and traps which aren't found on
the lush green fields of the surface
above including Ganon himself who also
made a home for himself deep below
Hyrule the English version of the manual
specifically refers to these
Subterranean dungeons as an underworld
however as has become common knowledge
among those invested in the lore of the
series The Western localization
particularly Nintendo of America tends
to misinterpret change or ignore some of
the Nuance present in the original
Japanese text sometimes by accident
sometimes purposely in Japanese there is
a clear separation between the
underground and the Underworld the first
being chick car which simply translates
to underground I.E a space below the
surface be it natural or man-made the
second kanji is Makai or Demon World
which is more so a fictional realm or
Nether world a place of death and Decay
and of course as the name suggests where
demons are said to reside the kanji used
in Zelda one's manual is the first one
chica in other words the labyrinths in
the game are not part of some sort of
Netherworld but are simply structures
located below the surface of Hyrule the
first use of Makai the Demon World is
found in Zelda 2's manual and refers to
a place from which ganon's minions are
plotting the resurrection of their Demon
King Makai would be used again in
Ocarina of Time to describe what the
sacred realm had become after Ganondorf
corrupted it a once sacred land
transformed into a hellish demonic
landscape but one one thing to keep in
mind is that the corrupted sacred realm
or dark world as it's called in A Link
to the Past is not the OG Demon World
where beings like demise and his tribe
of demons originally came from but
rather a location or World which has
been annexed by it drawing it into its
Dominion it's one of several Worlds the
forces of Darkness have been able to
successfully conquer albeits temporarily
the Twilight realm being another example
which despite its gloomy atmosphere did
not belong to the darkness until
Ganondorf brought it into these lands
with him when he got sealed inside of it
corrupting the realm and transforming
its inhabitants the Twilight into demons
in the process
however skyward Swords prologue explains
that there does in fact exist a world
where evil found its roots the original
home of the demon tribe which is implied
to lie deep below the Earth's crust
somewhere and that one fateful day evil
forces found a way to break out of this
Netherworld rushing forth from the
fissure and into the world above an
event so legendary that we find a
massive Landmark named after it in
breath of the wild countless ages later
there's a lot of mystery surrounding the
Demon World or world of Darkness as it
sometimes referred to because although
we've explored various lands which have
succumbed to its Rule and influence
we've never set foot or even seen the
actual demon Homeworld described in
Skyward Sword and yet it's an integral
part of the mythology of the Zelda
Universe it represents the opposing
Force to the heavens the gods and all
who support their cause you could say
it's this world's equivalent of hell
with the normal world or Earth if you
will stuck in between this endless
conflict between light and dark in fact
there's a dungeon in Skyward Sword which
acts as a sort of self-contained biome
that reflects the three primary layers
of the Zelda Universe a middle floor
representing the earth a giant lotus
flower at the top visualizing the
heavens and Enlightenment and a grim and
Eerie basement level which represents
the underworld with malice-filled Lakes
imagery of death and Decay and the
remains of long dead percoblins
reanimated by a substance described as
crystallized monster malice the
similarities between the underworld
inside the ancient system and the
otherworldly cave from the latest tears
of the Kingdom trailer are quite
noticeable a thick and hazy atmosphere
zombie-like enemies infested with malice
as well as an abundance of malice in
liquid form which is pooled together to
form large puddles and streams then of
course we have the spirit Flames which
also seem to be unique to this
underground location these type of ghost
flames tend to appear in the presence of
the deceased or when those who reside in
the light cross the veil of Shadow and
into the world of darkness in Twilight
Princess these people were not dead but
their nature as beings of the light
prevented them from maintaining a
physical form and so only their Essence
their Spirit remained visible which took
on the shape of a pale blue flame the
fact that we see almost identical Flames
down here suggests that this may indeed
be a sort of Dark World a place where
those from the surface are unable to
exist physically or they might actually
be dead who knows so if this is indeed
the fabled underworld or a demon world
the same place demise may have once
called home what does it mean for the
story of Tears of the Kingdom I mean
it's not like we've never visited dark
Realms or Dimensions before well from
what we've been able to see so far it
seems that we may see a repeat of the
events described in the ancient
backstory from Skyward Sword possibly on
an even bigger scale not only do we see
a brief glimpse of an environment that
would fit the description of a demonic
Netherworld but in many shots we can see
what looks like cracks or holes which
have formed in places on Hyrule surface
where previously there were none
furthermore in many cases malice has
seen boiling up from these crevices and
I don't just mean pools of malice like
the ones we saw so many of in breath of
the wild which were more or less
stagnant now the stuff we see here is
much more turbulent than that and is
boiling up to the surface in the form of
these tendrils there's quite a few shots
where we can spot these malice vents for
lack of a better term and in some cases
you can see that it forms a sort of Ring
Around the edge of the hole in fact they
look like smaller versions of what we
see happening at the castle and at the
summit of Death Mountain which also
feature these long strands of malice
snaking upwards with that said could
these openings act as portals or access
points which lead down to locations like
this a connection between Hyrule and
this potential Netherworld it would be
quite fitting because it looks like the
same thing is happening in the opposite
direction as well there's more and more
evidence that these green spirals we see
all across Hyrule are most likely a
connection between places on the surface
and specific Islands floating in the
skies above it and if that's true it
means we have two different types of
access points popping up all over Hyrule
those that lead to the realm in the sky
and those possibly granting access to a
world deep below it we've been able to
spot a deactivated or dormant version of
one of those green spirals it's
unmistakably the same structure however
there's no spiraling energy present at
this one suggesting that they have to be
activated before they can be used in
fact today's guest just so happens to
have made a whole video about this very
subject a few days ago so give that one
a watch if you're not convinced yet that
said if the green spirals need to be
activated in some way the same May apply
to some of these holes that potentially
lead to the underworld and we may have
already seen signs of this there's a
strange looking Boulder located on Death
Mountain and if you look closely it
seems to have a rune or scripture on it
maybe it's plugging up one of these
portals to the underworld and has yet to
be uncovered by removing the boulder
either by force or some sort of magic
power or spell a new area of the
Netherworld becomes available another
possible connection between the
underworld and the surface are these
oddly shaped trees or Roots the bottom
of which emits a faint yellow light we
can spot at least two of them in this
shot and they could just be decorative
to make the cave look more interesting
but what if they serve a more
significant purpose in the shot
overlooking hatteno Village you'll be
able to make out two strange looking
shapes on the town Plaza which were
definitely not there in breath of the
wild some have called them glowing
mushrooms and yeah I can see that but
it's hard to make out their true shape
given low resolution whatever they are
they too glow a similar yellow Hue as
those tree looking things in the
underground shot it's also the only
place in the entire trailer where we see
these strange flashes of light
flickering all over town and just so
happened to occur in close proximity to
these two glowing whatever they are so
could they be connected to the glowing
roots in the underground shot which also
happen to have these ghost flames nearby
weird flickering lights Spirit Flames I
think you can see why people are drawing
connections it's almost as if the
underworld is expanding above ground
taking root and maybe even drawing
people into it harvesting Souls perhaps
which I'll admit is very speculative and
it could be nothing or something
entirely different but it's an
interesting thought regardless the last
clue I want to touch upon and could
point to something big egg regarding the
world below the surface comes in the
form of the tears of the Kingdom
collector's edition it includes a
steelbook which reveals a missing piece
of the mural we were introduced to back
in September the one with the deity
figure standing on a platform in the sky
I've talked in the past about how the
section below the figure seems to
represent the surface of Hyrule there's
two shapes in the bottom left and right
Corners one of which looks to be a
stylized depiction of Death Mountain
which would make the other one the hebra
mountains as it lies at the opposite
side of the map at approximately the
same latitude the mural on the steelbook
reveals a group of humanoids locking
hands and staring up towards the figure
in the sky if it's true that these are
indeed Death Mountain in a section of
hebra that would make this line the
surface and means that these humanoids
are actually standing in a place below
ground of course this doesn't
necessarily prove the inclusion of a
netherworld but it does at least tend to
the significance of that which lies
below Hyrule in fact the mural seems to
depict the same three layers present at
the Ancient Cistern and the Zelda
mythology as a whole for that matter
that leaves us with one final question
if there is a dark Netherworld located
below Hyrule one which is slowly
expanding its influence on the world
above how would we go about exploring a
place like this I mean a world like the
one described in Skyward Sword would
have to be immensely deep down somewhere
with explored a plethora of locations
deep below hyrule's surface in the past
but never have we stumbled upon some
kind of portaled or border that crosses
into a Nether world of some kind
Netherworld also implies death or the
Afterlife exemplified by the ghost
flames present here would it even be
possible to Traverse a place like this
as a mere mortal well maybe we don't or
rather not as link anyway I think you
know where I'm going with this but I'm
going to stop you right there and
instead refer you to my video which
covers Zelda's fate and her possible
role in this story there is a whole
other side to this coin which might
surprise you so head on over to my
channel for the second half of this
collaboration and that concludes today's
video I hope we were able to bring some
interesting stuff to the table and as
the man said be sure to head over to
Celtics channel for a detailed look on
how this potential underworld might be
explored and by who hint hint a big
shout out to my mods my Discord
community and of course my patreons and
members of which I have quite a few new
phases to announce thank you so much to
M King yebo Anthony Young minduino
Daniel bookholds Sebastian Duran renyard
Nats lesso the art of mean Sir Nicholas
blue feather elf storm Matthew uler Dave
S and mccoblin blade master your
generosity is only rivaled by your
awesomeness thank you all so much and
that is all for now this is Dawn signing
off and have a good one
[Music]
thank you